as of Aikman was a thin little man with
bowlegs as a hook-nosed in the civilian
world he had been viewed as of near a
counter socially awkward laser with
little to redeem himself having joined
the Nazi Party however his unquestioning
commitment to orders coupled with his
need for ruthless efficiency allowed him
to carve out a career that would see him
go down as one of the greatest mass
murderers in human history in this
week's biographic sweet race the life
the crimes and the death of Adolf
Eichmann
[Music]
adolfo to Eichmann was born in Zola ghen
Germany on March the 19th 1906 to
bookkeeper Adolf Karl Eichmann and his
wife Maria the oldest of five children
young Adolf was a nervous shy child with
few friends when he was seven years old
his father moved two limbs to take a job
as a commercial manager for the city's
electrical provider with the rest of the
family following a year later in Linz
Adolph attended the Kaiser Franz Josef
secondary school the same school that
Adolph Hitler had attended in the 1890s
he remains an aloof and lonely child and
his parents worried about his lack of
social skills his dark complexion and
distinctive nose and ears led to his
schoolmates teasing him with the
nickname decline Judah or the little Jew
Adolphe proved to be a mediocre student
at best by the time he became a teenager
he had a reputation as being difficult
and moody with his father having written
him off as a no-hoper with little
promise of furthering an education he
quit school at the age of 15 and began
to train as a mechanic but this too he
proved to be a failure after two
frustrating years he gave up on this
career and took a job as a sales agent
for a mining company this job also
lasted for two years after which she
became the district agents for a normal
company by the age of 25 Eichmann was a
sullen withdrawn and socially inept
little man who could still be mistaken
for a Jew he had a stable but
uninspiring job that saw him working
around Upper Austria and Salzburg in
1932 despite having never shown any
interest in political affairs
he joined the National Socialist Party
his association with the party began at
the urging of a friends by the name of
Ernst Kaltenbrunner who was a party
official
[Music]
for Eichmann that the party would give
him an opportunity to belong to a group
and to advance his station in life more
than anything he wanted to be somebody
and wanted to prove to the world that he
had value as an individual in November
of 1932 he was accepted into the ranks
of the SS with his duties involving
forming part of the protection squad for
speakers at Party rallies as well as
guarding the party headquarters at Linz
at the same time he was still working
for the oil company a few weeks after
Hitler became Chancellor of Germany in
January of 1933 Eichmann lost his job
due to staff cutbacks he immediately
applied for active SS duty in Germany
this was accepted and he proved to be a
diligent follower of orders rising to
the rank of sure Fuehrer in just a few
months in November of 1933 he was
appointed to the administrative staff of
the Dachau concentration camp add up
shall I commence job was to keep a
detailed catalogue of all the items that
were being confiscated from incoming
Jewish prisoners he did his job well but
found it to be exceedingly boring around
this time he began to set his mind to
studying and inculcating the basic
principles of Nazism in summing up what
he had come to believe he said if they
had told me that my own father was a
traitor and I had to kill him I'd have
done it in an attempt to break out of
his monotonous routine at Dachau in 1934
Eichmann applied to join the SD which
was the security service of the SS his
application was successful and he was
transferred to the Nazi Party head
office in Berlin he was quickly promoted
to the rank of hubscher Fuhrer
I commence job was now to investigate
and create reports on the activities of
Jewish organizations in Germany he threw
himself into the work learning the
basics of the Hebrew language and
establishing himself as the Nazi Party
expert on the culture and the history of
the Jews around this time the
perennially Shai Eichmann met and fell
in love with Veronica Leigh ball after
the required vetting to ensure that she
had no Jewish heritage the couple were
married on March the 21st 1935 they
would go on to have four sons in 1937
Eichmann who now held the rank of
ss-untersturmführer or second left
tenants was sent on an important mission
to the British Mandate of Palestine
along with his superior officer he was
there to investigate the feasibility of
German Jews being forcibly made to
migrate to Palestine but the mission it
never got off the grounds with the
British refusing them entry into the
country in the wake of the annexation of
Austria Eichmann moved to Vienna with
the job of organizing the local SS there
his efficiency in doing so and in
another promotion this time to the rank
of ss obersturmfuhrer more first
lieutenant he was also selected to
initiate the central office for Jewish
emigration whose express purpose was to
force the expulsion of all Jews from
Austria
[Music]
Aikman threw himself into his new role
with an unusual zeal within eight months
he had strips the vast majority of Jews
in the country of all their lands and
their possessions and forced 45,000 to
leave ominously a further 150,000 simply
disappeared his efficiency though it
greatly impressed his superiors the
invasion of Poland on September the 1st
1939 and the subsequent outbreak of war
Hitler's policy towards the Jews changed
no longer would they be encouraged to
leave Germany from now on they would be
forcibly deported Jews were to be herded
together and sent to concentration camps
situated in newly aquired parts of the
Reich in October of 1939 Eichmann was
posted to Berlin where he worked
directly under Gustavo chief Heinrich
and Muller in establishing the
nationwide central office for Jewish
emigration his first job was to clear
specified areas of Poland of Jews at the
same time he continued his pet project
of ridding his beloved Vienna of the
Jewish problem he selected Misco in the
far north of Poland as the site for a
transit camp where the expelled Jews
would be gathered before sending them to
the harsh Russian wilderness in order to
fend for themselves meanwhile ethnic
Jews were being moved into the areas of
Poland where the Jews had been evicted
on December the 19th 1939 Eichmann
received yet another promotion he was
now the overall coordinator of Jewish
affairs and evacuation for the entire
German Reich all deportations to camps
in Poland were now under his ultimate
control many thousands of Jews were also
being sent to an area in the east of
Poland known as the general government
Eichmann immediately drew up plans to
send 600,000 Jews into the general
government but these plans were pushed
back due to complaints by authorities in
the East who were worried that too many
Jews would ruin the economy in the end
some 63,000 people were relocated to the
area with many of them dying in transit
all over occupied Europe Jews were
crowded into ghettos as they waited to
be sent away the conditions in the
ghettos they were appalling and many
people died before
they ever step foot on a train carriage
in 1940 Eichmann released a plan to
resettle a million people every year in
Madagascar his plan had relied on the
Luftwaffe conquering the British in the
Battle of Britain which would have
enabled the Germans to take control of
the skies over the Atlantic when this
failed to happen the plans for operation
Madagascar they were shelved
indefinitely
[Music]
in September of 1941 Eichmann was called
to a meeting with the head of the SD
reinhard heydrich in this meeting he was
informed that the Fuhrer had ordered
that all Jews in countries occupied by
Germany were to be put to death the
timeline for this was to swing into
action after the conquest of the Soviet
Union
however the entry of the United States
into the war following the Japanese
attack on Pearl Harbor forced a rethink
of this if the extermination of the Jews
was to be given maximum priority in 1942
Heydrich called a meeting of the major
players in the Nazi organization of von
Z on the outskirts of Berlin it was
during this meeting that an official
policy of Jewish genocide was laid out
Heydrich called it the final solution to
the Jewish Question Eichmann had
prepared for this meeting by creating
lists of the numbers of Jews in each
country who had to be exterminated
Heydrich then appointed him his
right-hand man a man responsible for
coordinating all of the trains that
would be used to carry Jews to polish
concentration camps as a result of the
constant supply of human fodder that
Eichmann was responsible for the death
camps at Auschwitz Dachau Treblinka and
Buchenwald became 24-hour killing
machines Eichmann funneled Jews and
gypsies from Austria Holland France the
Baltic States and Yugoslavia to their
slaughter often they were sent first to
Warsaw and other ghettos in Poland for
resettlement further east in a great
example of distorted perception Eichmann
wrote the following about his work Jewry
was grateful for the chance they gave it
to learn community life at the ghetto it
made an excellent school for the future
in Israel basically most Jews feel well
and happy in their ghetto life as the
months passed the demands placed on
Eichmann to speed up the killing machine
increased he was responsible for
supplying victims to a total of a
hundred and sixty four camps spread
throughout Eastern Europe in attempts to
make the process more efficient he
oversaw the enlargements of the death
drains still he gave no thought to
supplying those who were crammed into
the carriages for weeks on end with food
or water and many of them died on the
way Eichmann's organizational ability
was also employed to improve the
efficiency of the actual killing process
he designs the huge windowless rooms and
suggests
that they be disguised as shower units
in order to allay panic he also pushed
for the replacements of the relatively
inefficient carbon monoxide gas with the
cyanide based insecticide zyklon-b
we can get an insight into Eichmann's
ruthless efficiency by an incident which
occurred during a roundup of Jews in
Paris in 1942 7,000 people were rounded
up 4050 one of them being children
however the city powers objected to the
deportation and managed to secure talks
with Eichmann the Jews were holed up in
a warehouse without food or water for
six days Eichmann stared down the French
officials insisting that every single
Jew had to be sent east to their deaths
in 1944 Eichmann was transferred to
Hungary which had recently been overrun
by the Nazis he was tasked with fast
tracking the transportation of Hungarian
Jews to death camps something that he
did with ruthless efficiency in just a
few months he had condemned more than
400,000 of them
[Music]
by early in 1945 it was obvious to many
in the Nazi hierarchy that the game was
up with the Russians coming at them from
one side and the Allies closing in from
the other the priority for many became
personal survival reinhard heydrich
decided that the time had come to put an
end to the mass extermination of the
Jews and set about destroying any
evidence of the crimes against humanity
that had been authorized when I come in
heard about this he was not happy
he decided of his own volition to
continue and to even speed up the
killings but finally even he saw the
writing on the wall
his biggest fear seemed to be that he
would be sent out to the frontlines to
fight the Russians or the Americans in
march with the russians pouring into
hungary he fled to austria where he
tried to get his old friend and skelton
Brunner to help him evade capture by the
Allies but the intimate involvement that
Eichmann had had with the Jewish
slaughter had made him a dangerous man
to associate with and Carleton Brenner
who was trying to save his own skin
wanted nothing to do with him shortly
thereafter Eichmann was captured by the
US Army having given a false name he was
transferred between several POWs camps
he was part of a work detail in Cham and
Germany when he escaped he managed to
secure new identity papers and took on
the identity of Otto
Hennigan and he relocated to lüneburg
heath in lower saxony he later found
work in the forestry sector other
members of the Nazi hierarchy were not
as fortunate as Eichmann in their
attempts to evade justice many of them
ended up at the Nuremberg war trials
where they gave detailed evidence about
the role that Eichmann had played in the
systematic planning and extermination of
the Jews as a result of this he became
one of the most sought after Nazi war
criminals in 1950 Eichmann relocated to
Italy here he received the assistance of
Al wahoo dal a Roman Catholic bishop he
was a Nazi sympathizer and had already
helped many Nazis get out of Europe but
all helped Eichmann obtain a
humanitarian passport from the
International Committee of the Red Cross
along with fake identification and
landing permits for Argentina with these
documents he was able to secure an
international passport from the Red
Cross he now had everything he needed to
sail for South America he departed from
Genoa on June the 17th 1950 and arrived
in Buenos Aires on July the 14th
[Music]
for the next two years under the name of
Ricardo Klement Eichmann worked for a
government contractor in tucumán
province after two years he felt secure
enough to bring over his wife and sons
they moved to Buenos Aires where
Eichmann worked in a series of menial
jobs before finding employment with
mercedes-benz over the next few years he
would employ his natural organizational
skills to rise to the position of
department head beginning in 1956 a
neo-nazi fanatic began interviewing
Eichmann at his home with the goal of
writing a fawning biography for this
project a large and damning collection
of tapes transcripts and notes were
produced meanwhile a handful of
determined Nazi hunters were hot on
Eichmann's trail prominent among them
was former concentration camp inmate
Simon Wiesenthal in 1953 Wiesenthal had
found a postcard in which a former Nazi
victim had mentioned seeing that pig
Eichmann in Buenos Aires he passed this
information on TV Israeli consulate in
Vienna the American CIA were also aware
that Eichmann was in South America
however they were unwilling to act on
the information for fear of embarrassing
themselves in the post for years the
Americans unemployed a number of Nazis
to work on the Manhattan atomic bomb
project they didn't want to go near
anything that would allow that
information to leak to the public
meanwhile Wiesenthal was working with
the Israeli intelligence service Mossad
to build a picture of Eichmann's life in
Argentina a break in the case came when
Eichmann's second oldest son got
involved with the daughter of a
Holocaust survivor who had relocated to
Argentina the WYD against a boast that
his father had worked for Hitler and was
in fact the brains behind the final
solution of the Jewish Question the girl
promptly reported this information back
to her father who in turn informed the
Israeli authorities Mossad sent an
operative to Buenos Aires to confirm
Eichmann's location and his identity it
was now up to Israeli Prime Minister
David ben-gurion to decide whether to
proceed diplomatically or to simply
cease Eichmann and bring him back to
Israel to face the music
knowing that the Argentinians had a
record of declining extradition requests
involving former Nazis ben-gurion
decided to take Eichmann by force an
eight-man team of Mossad operatives were
sent to Argentina to carry
the mission the operation was carried
out on May the 11th 1960 as Eichmann was
walking home from work two agents
pretended to be working on a car as he
walked past a third agent approached and
asked him for a cigarette I can I'd the
man nervously and in that moment all
three agents sprang upon him one of them
a black belt in karate delivered a blow
to his neck which rendered him
unconscious Eichmann was bundled into a
car and taken to a safe house where he
was stripped naked and examines under
his right arm it's the agents found they
partially removed tattoo which confirmed
that he was a member of the SS on May
the 21st day heavily sedated Eichmann
was smuggled out of Argentina on a
commercial flight that was bound for
Israel
[Music]
when Prime Minister ben-gurion announced
that the Most Wanted Nazi in the world
had been captured it caused an
international sensation the Argentinian
strongly protested the manner of the
abduction claiming that it had been a
violation of Argentinean sovereignty
then Gurion replied that Eichmann had
been captured not by agents of the
Israeli governments but by individual
citizens the trial of Adolf Eichmann
began on April the 11th 1961 in Israel's
Bethan house of the people 15 charges
were levelled against him including
crimes against humanity the charges
encompassed the view that he was the man
in direct control of the entire Nazi
bureaucratic structure responsible for
the deaths of millions of people before
and during the war Ivan's trial was
broadcast live on TV stations around the
globe after listening to the emotional
testimony of Holocaust survivors and
others Eichmann didn't try to deny the
facts his sole defense was that he was
simply carrying out orders he stated
that he never did anything great or
small without obtaining in advance
express instructions from a doff Hitler
or any of my superiors the trial took 14
weeks at the end of which Eichmann was
convicted on all counts the sentence was
death by hanging his defense team made
an unsuccessful appeal for clemency
which was turned down by the new Israeli
prime minister the execution was carried
out on June the 1st 1962 at Israel's
Rambla prison Eichmann refused the black
coat that was offered to him on the
gallows his final words were long-lived
Germany long live Austria
long live Argentina these other
countries with who I have been most
closely associated and I shall not
forget them I had to obey the rules of
my war and my flag I am ready I commence
body was cremated and his ashes
scattered in international waters in the
Mediterranean Sea so I really hope you
enjoyed that episode of biographic if
you did there's a couple of things you
could do right now one is hit that like
button below also if you want more stuff
like this we put out brand new videos
every Monday and every Thursday so hit
that subscribe button below and
subscribe button doesn't do what it used
to on YouTube if you actually want to
get a notification about these videos
please do hit that Bell button next to
the subscribe button and that'll send
you a notification every time every
Monday and Thursday won't put out a new
video also if you want to watch
something else
right now
stuff from the archive over there on the
right and as always thank you for
watching
you
[Music]